[Musik]
die nachrichten
in allen ein ganz herzliches willkommen
freut mich sehr dass jan dabei sind an
diesem samstagabend christin autos hat
bei mir im studio mit guten nachrichten
vom wetter sehr schöne erfolge kunde amt
dann blicken wir jetzt auf die themen im
überblick
scharfe kritik an booster plänen des
gesundheitsministeriums anstelle von
ballack soll überwiegend moderner für
auffrischungsimpfungen verwendet werden
brasilien schafft die wende nachdem
hunderttausende an corinna starben sind
dort inzwischen die allermeisten geimpft
und
perfekter saisonstart für karl geiger
der oberstdorfer gewinnt in russland den
weltcup-auftakt im skispringen
[Musik]
damit im stoff von moderner nicht
verfällt sollen arztpraxen pro woche nur
noch 30 dosen vom gängigsten impfstoff
bayern tag bestellen dürfen dieser
vorstoß von gesundheitsminister spahn
stößt auf massive kritik ärzte und
politiker warnen vor einer
verunsicherung der bevölkerung auf einer
pressekonferenz vor wenigen minuten
bekräftigte sparen noch einmal beide
impfstoffe bayern tag und moderner seien
sehr sicher antoine kurschilgen
berichtet
riesenandrang heute im nordrhein
westfälischen ibbenbüren sonder
impfaktionen in diesem test center in
der innenstadt der ansturm so groß dass
der impfstoff nicht für alle reicht
künftig mehr moderner weniger biontech
viele hier sind verunsichert die leute
haben den eindruck die sind irritiert
die haben den eindruck dass wichtige das
gute ist nicht mehr da und jetzt muss
man auf das zweitbeste produkt umsteigen
aus dem bundesgesundheitsministerium
heißt es heute schriftlich es ist genug
impfstoff für alle da das ende des
jahres stehen 50 millionen dosen an m
rna impfstoffen von beyoncé und moderner
für erst- zweit- und insbesondere
auffrischimpfungen zur verfügung beide
impfstoffe sind sicher wirksam und
gleich gut für auffrischimpfungen
geeignet arztpraxen und impfzentren
bestellen so viel impfstoff wie seit
monaten nicht allein nächste woche
werden sechs millionen dosen von
biontech ausgeliefert das heißt aber
auch unser lager läuft gerade und
deswegen müssen wir eben zusätzlich zum
impfstoff von biontech auch den von
moderner stärker wieder mit einsätzen
die millionenfach eingelagerten moderner
dosen drohen zu verfallen deswegen soll
weniger impfstoff von bayern zeigt
ausgeliefert werden nur noch 30 dosen
pro praxis und woche die begrenzungen
der biontech lieferung sind im moment
eine katastrophe eigentlich gerade auch
für die praxen aber die impfzentren
patientinnen und patienten sind
einbestellt die impfbereitschaft ist
hoch und wir müssen das jetzt
unterstützen wir brauchen den turbo und
keine handbremse piontek und moderner
sind m rna impfstoffe moderner ist aber
höher konzentriert das kann bei männern
unter 30 zu gesundheitlichen problemen
führen deswegen wird hier der impfstoff
von bayerns empfohlen bei allen anderen
könnten bauern zeigt und moderner
problemlos kombiniert werden sagen
experten
das maximale antwort herausgeholt werden
kann die verunsicherung bei vielen
impfwilligen wird wohl dennoch bleiben
zumindest vorerst
und wir bleiben bei einem impfen da
fordern politiker und mediziner mehr
tempo aber wenn viele gleichzeitig eine
auffrischungsimpfung wollen wie aktuell
dann wird es problematisch
hausärzte alleine werden den andrang
nicht bewältigen können darum sprechen
sich immer mehr so wie heute die
niedersächsische gesundheitsministerin
behrens dafür aus dass auch apotheker
impfen dürfen dazu stefan schlosser
hausarzt christian sommer brot versucht
im chaos ruhe zu bewahren telefone
stehen nicht mehr still das e mail
postfach quillt über ob erste zweite
oder dritte impfung die nachfrage ist in
kürzester zeit sprunghaft angestiegen
mit dem aufruf der bundesregierung dass
sich alle ostern können haben sich auch
natürlich alle angemeldeten das hat die
praxen fast schlagartig ins chaos
geführt die priorisierung die wir am
anfang der pandemie hatten die uns viel
geholfen hat da ein vernünftiges
terminmanagement aufzubauen fiel diesmal
völlig impfzentren wurden geschlossen
schnellstmöglich müssen neue strukturen
aufgebaut werden dabei könnten apotheken
helfen in vielen werden schon lange test
durchgeführt es gab auch schon
pilotprojekte zu grippeimpfungen in
einigen bundesländern apotheken könnten
also mit in findet claudia
die menschen die zu uns kommen und wir
haben ein niederschwelliges angebot so
dass wir dadurch die impfquote wirklich
erhöhen können doch nicht alle haben die
räumlichen und personellen
voraussetzungen und apotheker sind keine
ärzte was wenn es in reaktionen gibt
wenn dann irgendwie doch jemanden
kreislaufprobleme kommt das kommt hin
und wieder vor muss derjenige ins
krankenhaus kann nicht in der apotheke
versorgt werden das überlastet die
notaufnahmen die eh schon am limit
laufen viel wichtiger sei meinen
christian sommer brot dass die praxen
mit ausreichend impfstoff versorgt
werden der sei nämlich schon wieder
knapp
und das vor dem hintergrund steigender
infektionszahlen das robert koch
institut meldet 63
1924 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 18 1843 mehr als vor einer
woche
248 todesfälle kamen dazu die sieben
tage incident steigt weiter auf aktuell
362,2 die hospitalisierung rate also der
neue light indikator wird am wochenende
nicht veröffentlicht auch in sachsen
steigen die zahlen weiter die sieben
tage incidents liegt dort aktuell bei
fast 800 darum hat die landesregierung
wie zuvor bayern auch schon angekündigt
das öffentliche leben herunterzufahren
ab montag für drei wochen und das
bedeutet weihnachtsmärkte und andere
großveranstaltungen werden abgesagt
theater bars und clubs geschlossen für
den einzelhandel gilt die 2g regel
ausgenommen sind geschäfte zur
grundversorgung etwa supermärkte darüber
hinaus soll es für ungeimpfte in
landkreisen mit einer inzidenz über 1000
eine nächtliche ausgangssperre geben
thomas bärsch berichtet
für manuel metzger kamen die nachrichten
des letzten abends einer katastrophe
gleich der dresdner striezelmarkt zu und
seine ware kann er nicht einfach
einlagern und nächstes jahr noch einmal
anbieten seine ware wird zum teil
verderben unser käse
das lebensmittel also für uns konkret
heißt das die ware die wir jetzt hier
aktuell haben werden wir in keiner weise
in den nächsten vier wochen irgendwie
verkauft bekommen ein lockdown lag seit
wochen in sachsen in der luft
überraschend er dass die entscheidung
nun erst kam viele hatten dann doch noch
hoffnung geschöpft und auf zwei gesetzt
doch zweig hat bis jetzt seine wirkung
verfehlt die korona zahlen steigen und
so zieht sachsen ab montag notbremse mit
konsequenzen auch jetzt schon hotels zum
beispiel bleibt nur das wochenende um
angemeldeten feriengästen abzusagen und
natürlich haben sie auch hier mit der
entscheidung dass es dort maßnahmen
geben musste selbstverständlich
inwiefern so drastisch wie wir sie jetzt
gegangen sind das richtig ist
dass entscheiden wieder andere die
maßnahmen treffen fast jeden sachsen und
kommen einem teil london gleich dennoch
finden sie auf der straße heute auch
viel verständnis für die leute die hier
ihre existenz auf dem spiel stehen ist
natürlich schlimm aber
zu ändern ist es halt nicht es muss
jetzt sein es ist schon eine schwierige
situation vor allen dingen weil immer
noch leute gibt die sich nicht impfen
lassen die neue verordnung gilt ab
montag erst einmal bis mitte dezember
dann wird man weitersehen und nach
steuern
stark betroffene bundesländer fahren
also langsam wieder runter vor allem
wegen der lage auf den intensivstationen
in vielen kliniken werden die betten
knapp beim personal ist das ja längst
der fall zahlreiche pflegerinnen und
pfleger haben wegen der hohen belastung
aufgegeben das wiederum erhöht den
stress und den frust über die vielen
ungeimpften notfälle susanne santino
intensivpfleger hendrik i deshalb kann
verstehen dass viele seiner kolleginnen
und kollegen vor allem im letzten jahr
wegen überbelastung auch psychischer
gekündigt haben er selbst hat
weitergemacht sorgt sich aber zunehmend
weil er merkt wie sich die situation
immer weiter zuspitzt die kogit
intensivbetten in frankfurter sind alle
belegt im moment kriegen was noch hin
aber wer weiß was jetzt im nächsten
winter kommt dafür aber viele
pflegekräfte einfach wieder angst man
hat jetzt die hoffnung gehabt dass sich
möglichst viele leute natürlich impfen
lassen und wir dadurch nur noch die
impfstoff bekommen aber im moment ist ja
so dass wir auch relativ viele
ungeimpfte haben drei von acht patienten
die hier liegen sind geimpft alle mit
vorerkrankungen vor allem die
ungeimpften mussten ins künstliche koma
versetzt werden werden invasiv beatmet
was ihre überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit
auf 50 prozent senkt oberarzt daniel
bock kann nicht verstehen dass ich so
viele nicht impfen lassen obwohl sie
könnten die jetzige lage sieht er sehr
kritisch mit hoch wahrscheinlich dazu
führen dass wir die nächsten wochen
monate er in meinen augen und zwar bis
april mai wieder prinzip die gleiche
situation erfahren werden wie letztes
jahr ich denke auch die zahlen könnten
unter umständen sogar noch höher werden
diese im intensivpatienten geht es
mittlerweile besser er hatte mit der
impfung lange gezögert was er jetzt
braucht er infizierte sich nach der
ersten impfung als der schutz noch nicht
ausreichend war
die folge sinfonie von uns hoch wenn ich
vorher gewusst hätte ich das vorher
gemacht weil ich einen fehler jene wurde
verantwortungsvoll ist schimpfen zu
lassen
heute konnte der 60-jährige auf die
normale station verlegt werden dank der
tollen betreuung durch ärzte und pfleger
sagt er ihnen ist er sehr dankbar
auch österreich stehen ja corona
verschärfungen bevor ab montag ein
landesweiter lockdown außerdem hat die
regierung eine impfpflicht für alle
angekündigt gegen beide maßnahmen gab es
heute proteste rund 35.000 menschen
zogen durch die straßen und sammelten
sich auf dem heldenplatz die polizei
sprach von einer aufgeheizten stimmung
es gab mehrere festnahmen
aufgerufen zur demonstration hatte unter
anderem die rechtsgerichtete fpö
demos gegen weitere corona maßnahmen
auch bei unseren anderen nachbarn den
niederländern nicht die ersten aber
gestern sei es eine orgie der gewalt
gewesen so der bürgermeister von
rotterdam im zentrum der hafenstadt kam
es am späten abend zu schweren
ausschreitungen
die polizei feuerte warnschüsse ab die
vorläufige bilanz sieben verletzte
ausgebrannte autos und über 50
festnahmen in den niederlanden gilt seit
einer woche wieder ein teil lockdown
monate lang gab es aus brasilien nur
düstere corona nachrichten immer neue
höchststände bei den zahlen das
gesundheitssystem in vielen regionen
kollabiert kaum ein land auf der welt
hat so viele tote zu beklagen 600
600 1370 menschen haben ihr leben
verloren aber die situation hat sich
geändert seit ende juni sinkt die zahl
der neu infektionen rasant kaum noch
jemand stirbt ankurbelt der grund die
hohe impfquote über den wandel und das
warum jetzt christoph bröcker rat hatte
linus silber bei der letzte patient in
der nur für corona reservierten klinik
rios und der bürgermeister lässt es sich
nicht nehmen ihn bei der entlassung zu
begleiten mit 95 prozent vollständig
geimpft erwachsener art rio de janeiro
das virus nun unter kontrolle
im gleichen maße wie die impfungen
vorangeschritten sind ist die zahl der
erkrankten und toten zurückgegangen in
allen landesteilen brasiliens ist die
entwicklung ähnlich
wir sind sehr stolz darauf dass sich die
brasilianische bevölkerung jetzt impfen
lässt und auf die lage reagiert die
wissenschaft und die fakten respektiert
und nicht den quatsch glaubt der da im
umlauf ist
so hatte präsident paul szenario es
kürzlich behauptet durch die impfung
könne man an aids erkranken doch solche
aussagen verfangen bei der mehrheit der
brasilianer nicht zu viele haben
angehörige verloren hinzu kommt dass
brasilien flächendeckend über
impfzentren verfügt wir haben eine lange
tradition des impfens ich denke unsere
entwicklung ist ein beispiel für die
welt es ist möglich die pandemie zu
besiegen die krankheit zu kontrollieren
aber dazu müssen alle mitmachen
mit mehr als 600.000 corona toten haben
die brasilianer einen hohen preis
bezahlt für falschinformationen
politisches versagen und die anfangs
verschleppte impfkampagne umso
entschlossener sind sie jetzt sich
impfen zu lassen und der extreme
rückgang der korona zahlen gibt ihnen
recht
im ganzen land geht die impfkampagne
weiter auch booster impfungen sind
bereits verfügbar
brasilien kommt dem leben nach corona
immer näher
weiter nach oben auf dem kontinent in
die usa dort führt ein gerichtsurteil
das land auf ein 18-jähriger dabei
antirassismus protesten zwei menschen
erschossen hatte ist freigesprochen
worden es sei notwehr gewesen so die
jury auslöser im august 2020 in kenia im
bundesstaat wisconsin da gab es
demonstrationen nachdem ein weißer
polizist an den afroamerikaner mit
schüssen schwer verletzte
dritten haus damals 17 zog mit einer
bewaffneten gruppe durch die straßen um
nach eigenen angaben plünderungen zu
verhindern mehr jetzt von johannes hahn
es war ein freispruch erster klasse
unschuldig in allen anklagepunkten
überwältigt von seinen gefühlen sagt kai
dritten haus im gerichtssaal zusammen
freunde und angehörige der opfer aber
sind fassungslos
wenn das leben von einem oder zwei
menschen nichts zählt erzählt das leben
von niemandem von uns entweder zehn alle
oder keines und in diesem falle das
leben der opfer nicht gezählt
dritten haus hatte bei black light mit
dass protesten in kinos wisconsin zwei
menschen erschossen und einen schwer
verletzt
damals 17 jahre alt war mit einem
schnellfeuergewehr es im benachbarten
illinois angereist wo die gemeinsam mit
rechten milizen für recht und ordnung
sorgen jetzt der freispruch
er will mit seinem leben weitermachen
dann fällt eine last von den schultern
durch das was die geschworenen wir haben
heute zuteil werden lassen
nicht von all dem wäre je geschrieben
rechte gruppen feiern ritten haus jetzt
als helden auf den amerika gewartet habe
mehrere republikanische abgeordnete
bieten ihm einen praktikumsplatz an
sehen ihn als vorbild
mit dem haus ist und show die freunde
ihr habt das recht auf
selbstverteidigung seit bewaffnet
gefährlich tugendhaft in der nacht gab
es in mehreren städten proteste gegen
das urteil wie hier in new york ein
urteil das das land weiter spaltet
wir machen mit dem sport weiter da gab
es heute tolle erfolge für die deutschen
vor allem im eiskanal präsent ob die
deutschen bobs und ein großartiger
saison einstieg für die rodler auf der
olympia bahn nahe peking dreifach
triumph für die männer im einzel und ein
sieg für die doppelsitzer dazu die erste
weltcup podestplatz für lena dürr im
slalom in levi fi nanz
freudentränen acht jahre nach ihrem
bisher einzigen sieg gelingt lena dörr
endlich der sprung aufs podest im slalom
die 30 jährige fährt einen perfekten
zweiten durchgang und landet am ende
hinter den beiden slalom stars petra
wilmer slowakei und der amerikanerin
micaela schifrin auf rang drei bei den
test events in china dominieren die
deutschen rodler johannes ludwig sieg
mit bahnrekord von olympiasieger felix
loch und max langenhan ein
dreifacherfolg auf der neuen olympiabahn
in peking und bei den doppelsitzern
triumphierend toni eggert und sascha
benecken vor zwei schlitten aus
österreich gut zwei monate vor den
winterspielen präsentieren sich die
deutschen schon in gold fonds
und einen verheißungsvollen start in die
olympia saison erwischte auch
skispringer karl geiger der
skiflug-weltmeister aus oberstdorf
gewann im russischen nischni tagil das
erste weltcupspringen des winters vor
dem japaner kobayashi
wenige stunden vor dem fußball zweitliga
duell gegen schalke ist bremens trainer
markus anfang zurückgetreten dem 47
jährigen wird vorgeworfen einen
gefälschten impfpass benutzt zu haben
die staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt
das bremer gesundheitsamt hatte bei
markus anfangen unstimmigkeiten bei den
impf daten ausgemacht und strafanzeige
erstattet der trainer wies die vorwürfe
zurück stellte seinen posten heute aber
zur verfügung auch co-trainer florian
junge gegen den ebenfalls ermittelt wird
trat zurück was ihm vorgeworfen wird ist
bislang nicht bekannt die
staatsanwaltschaft hatte der deutschen
presse agentur mit eine mögliche
fälschung des imf ausweises lasse sich
zeitnah klären erst da nur halben jahr
war markus anfang chef trainer des
bundesliga absteigers beim spiel des
tabellen achten am abend gegen schalke
04 soll co trainer daniel zenkovich das
team betreuen
ja der druck auf den profifußball wächst
die stadien sind trotz der angespannten
kronlage noch gut gefüllt hier die
erstliga ergebnisse dortmund stuttgart
21 bielefeld wolfsburg 2 2 hoffenheim
leipzig 20 leverkusen bochum 1 0
gladbach führt 40 0 ausführlich das
berliner derby union hertha im aktuellen
sportstudio gestern augsburg 2 1 gegen
die bayern dadurch ist der vorsprung des
tabellen spitzenreiter auf dortmund auf
einen punkt geschrumpft leverkusen nun
vor wolfsburg und leipzig am
tabellenende rückt augsburg vor
stuttgart schlusslicht führt bleibt nach
zwölf spieltagen ohne sieg und viel mehr
noch zum fußball im sportstudio 23 uhr
aber alles falsch getippt dankeschön
christin regen wird eine größere rolle
spielen mehr dazu gleich in den
aussichten mit es denn terry nachher im
heute journal um viertel vor elf begrüßt
sie marietta slomka das gesamte heute
team bedankt sich fürs zuschauen wünscht
einen maximal entspannten samstagabend
und wenn sie mögen sehen wir uns morgen
wieder um 7
[Musik]
ein schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine kaltfront
erreicht uns von norden her und die
bringt viele wolken etwas regen aber
auch dahinter auflockerungen so wird es
dann zum nachmittag morgen auch etwas
sonnenschein geben im norden
deutschlands in der nacht kommt also der
regen erst einmal im nordwesten an der
er zieht allmählich langsam südwärts
auch im westen regnet es und auch an der
ostsee ganz im süden herrscht nebel
teilweise klart es auf die sterne zeigen
sich und dann wird es wieder mal leise
kalt bis -3 grad generell in
baden-württemberg und in bayern
temperaturen um die frost marke ganz im
norden wird es etwas milder bleiben mit
9 grad an der nordsee morgen
tagesverlauf verlagern sich die schauer
weiter südwärts dahinter lockert es dann
auf so trockner und mit sonnenschein in
der mitte dominieren die wolken regnet
es aber der regen der verhungert in der
mitte ganz in den süden kommt er erst
mal nicht voran dort herrscht nebel oder
sonne vor allem in den höheren lagen
zehn grad meistens nach norden und 5
grad im vogtland der regen wandert dann
am motorrad weiter in den süden es kann
im zoom generell auch mal sprühregen
geben im norden gibt sonnenschein drei
bis acht grad und am dienstag etwas
ruhiger und auch kühler ein schöner
abend